in this video we're going to talk about
how to write the cost function the
revenue function the profit function as
well as how to find the break even point
so let's dive in we've got a company
that manufactures teddy bears for $150
each and it has equipment costs of
$2,500 each teddy bear sells for $4 each
can you write a cost
function a revenue
function a profit function
and then can you find the break even
point so let's take this one step at a
time now some equations that you might
want to write down or memorize are the
basic slope intercept form of the
equation of a line as well as your
profit equation which remember profit is
equal to the revenue the money that you
take in minus the cost the expenses or
what you spend going out so that
difference is your leftover which is
your profit right so let's break this
down one step at a time so for the cost
let's say C of X or X is the number of
teddy bears
sold it's going to cost
$1.50 times x the number of teddy bears
that you're making or
manufacturing plus it also costs you the
initial expense of the
$2,500 for the equipment so remember
when you think of the slope or the M
value that's like the rate like how much
it costs per teddy bear to make whereas
the B that's our Y intercept or our
initial condition or our starting amount
and these are our starting expenses the
2,500 that's just a fixed or constant
cost whereas this is going to increase
as you make more and more teddy bears so
that's our cost function now the revenue
function that's how much money that
you're making right when you sell these
teddy bears and they're saying that we
sell them for $4 each so it's going to
be $4 times the number of teddy bears
that you sell if you sell 10 it's going
to be four time 1040 $40 that you're
taking in and then our profit is again
like we said the difference so we're
going to say p ofx is equal to R ofx our
Revenue minus our expenses or our costs
now one mistake that students sometimes
make is they forget to use parentheses
so our revenue is 4X our cost is this
whole thing so let's put it in
parentheses let's treat it like a
group and now what we're going to do is
we're just going to distribute this
negative -1 into the parentheses which
is going to make this
a1. 5x minus
2500 and if we combine like terms let's
see 4x -
1.5x is
2.5x minus
2,500 and that's our profit okay as a
function of the number of teddy
bears okay X now to find the break even
Point what is the break even well
basically the break even is when the
amount of money that you've taken in is
the exact same amount as the cost for
your expenses going out so really that
profit at that break even point is going
to be zero after which then you start to
become profitable so what we're going to
do is we're going to set this P of X
here equal to zero and we're going to
solve so let's go ahead and do that
we've got zero equal
2.5x minus
2,500 I'm going to add the 2500 to both
sides to get the variable by
itself
okay and so you can see we have 2,500 is
equal to 2.5x we're trying to solve for
the number of teddy bears that need to
be uh sold and made uh in order to make
uh a profit of zero that's our break
even so divide both sides by 2.5 and
2,500 divided 2.5 is equal to
1,000 teddy
bears and that would be your break even
point so once you sell th1 then you're
into the uh black uh as far as being
profitable and if you sell less than
this you're in the red whereas you're uh
still in the you know basically you
haven't made money yet you haven't
broken even so great job if you want to
see another example where I talk about
profit Revenue cost I'll put another
video right there follow me over to that
video and try maybe some of those
problems on your own for extra practice
I'll see you in that video